there's a new marvel movie out
apparently nobody likes it but it's
directed by a woman
which means you aren't allowed to not
like it
here's a critic from i think he's from
variety explaining why if you don't like
this this movie it's just because you're
you're a sexist
internals from director and co-writer
chloe zhao has opened in theaters
critics have weighed in on it and it has
been very divisive actually drawing the
lowest rated rotten tomatoes score of
any mcu film
in history thus far
first of all elizabeth it is not a bad
movie in the slightest i think it's one
of marvel's best efforts thus far has
great action it focuses a lot on story
it's diverse has great characters all
that i think this speaks to a larger
problem that is in the industry anytime
a woman takes on the action genre which
has been typically made for men to helm
people come harder on that filmmaker
when she takes it on i think it's i
think it's the issue that needs to be
addressed because it does not draw that
criticism that it's been receiving i
agree with you 100 right when you
started talking about this i said hmm
imagine that the film that is directed
by a woman has the lowest score on
rotten tomatoes not
warranted they really they only know one
tune that's all they know you gotta
you gotta feel uh sorry for them a
little bit they're they're humming the
only tune they know
um
yeah of course the exact opposite is
actually true
the exact opposite
it women
directors are given much more i mean
critics bend over backwards to find
reasons to like films directed by women
that's that's the reality
now i haven't seen eternals but um
something tells me if it's getting a if
it if a superhero movie
helmed by a woman and starring a diverse
cast is getting bad reviews on rotten
tomatoes it must be the worst movie ever
made because they will look for any re
they will cling on to anything
that they can find
they'll look for any handle to cling
onto anything
so that they could justify giving it a
positive review and if they can't i mean
i almost want to see this movie now
just because it's that bad
this is a woke mar critics love marvel
movies
um
and they they love woke movies they love
movies that are that are directed by
women
the guy there says a diverse cast they
love all of that
what could possibly have gone wrong in
that movie that would make them give it
a bad review that's amazing i'm amazed
by that
you have to try hard i mean you as a
woman director you have to try very very
hard
to earn bad reviews
got to respect it in some ways
um
why don't people like it well probably
because it's bad but but also consider
this this as well that maybe people are
in terms of the audience anyway maybe
not critics but
the audience might be tired of superhero
movies a little bit by now
like 20 years
straight of 50 superhero movies a year
at a certain point maybe people get
tired of it that's my theory listen hit
that subscribe button right now do it
right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated